[Musica]
grande piacere essere qui con voi e
provare a raccontarvi in pochissimi
minuti anche qual è la mia attività io
dirigo un istituto di ricerca che lavora
esattamente in questa dimensione
concetti per il futuro che ho provato ad
applicare alla bellezza
partendo da quattro grandi paradigmi
cioè dimensioni che stanno cambiando il
nostro mondo anche se molto spesso non
lo sappiamo e quindi ho provato come ci
chiede ted di cambiare prospettiva e di
fornirvi un riff inc strategie possibili
per affrontare in modo più intelligente
e anche positivo questo stesso futuro
partiamo allora dal primo è stato io
credo nei due interventi precedenti già
chiarito molto bene questo tema del
condividere molto importante
spesso la bellezza non viene condivisa
questo è un grande problema ad esempio
dell'italia ma anche un grande problema
delle persone molto spesso le persone
molto belle vengono invidiate e magari
hanno difficoltà a creare relazioni
oppure vengono solo ammirate ma
considerate in un altro mondo
ecco questa dimensione di calò segat os
come direbbero i greci significa quando
c'è la bellezza el estetica che ci sia
anche l'etica che ci siano anche valori
questo vuol dire trasformare la bellezza
da una qualità che hai in una virtù che
pratichi questa è una cosa molto
importante allora quello che io ho
provato a fare in questi pochi minuti è
per ciascuno di questi paradigmi e
questo è il primo fiducia e condivisione
proporvi un contributo video perché
secondo me è importante parlare di
bellezza ma anche molto bello vederla la
bellezza quindi partiamo col primo video
e poi continuerò su questo tema
[Musica]
[Applauso]
beh
[Musica]
oggi da era e rocco tambè niente uguale
[Applauso]
roma
[Musica]
foggia medaille aradori
maria 2
[Applauso]
maria cv
by michele botta
ma nemici e senti ma qui
[Musica]
[Applauso]
cross di coda e crude che juan cruz
[Musica]
the entrance
dai cortei
[Musica]
dai qualora
dai nei sinti nun me rai
dai la tv in acqua
nesci piccolo al rai con sinti con tom
cannes marcis ecco mi sembrava bello
partire con questa tra l'altro che una
visione che ci arriva da un paese come
la thailandia quindi non esattamente un
paese che osserviamo per comprendere
quello che avviene nel mondo
però questa idea di una bellezza che
anche bellezza del gesto che e bellezza
ad esempio di dare qualcosa che l'altro
non si aspetta è un elemento secondo
secondo noi è molto importante
secondo passaggio altrettanto importante
la diversità
noi siamo abituati in questi ultimi anni
a pensare che tutti noi ci stiamo
omologando io dal sociologo vi dico che
questo non è assolutamente vero vi dico
che oggi ad esempio dai territori stanno
emergendo diversità che sono molto
locali e che però devono giocare la
sfida del globale devono accettare
l'idea di avere una visione universale
non possiamo chiuderci nei nostri muri
ma avere questa visione pur conservando
la nostra bellezza
dal punto di vista dell'unicità questo
vuol dire imparare a riconoscere la
diversità senza pregiudizi ed ecco
allora che questo secondo video
credo che sia una sorta di tecnica che
io vi spingerà ad utilizzare nella
nostra vita quotidiana
[Musica]
tutto che tra vasche si trova pure che
per tenere stata una panda
prof
e se signore quello percepito mio
passato un dio perché poi chernoff e
un'anima d'oro del ballarin crediamo
nessuno e forte che non è attiva
le usate per ricordare ricerche su un
camper che fondano civiltà che confonda
con tante noi interessa alla società e
la pensa che lo sballo resca che nello
score nel suo in dio non soltanto
tanto forte come come penso che una
persona
talmente violento aggressivo incontro
solo per la cagliese che mi dà via mio
[Musica]
pochi secondi per costruire un
pregiudizio ma altrettanto pochi secondi
anche per spezzarlo
basta incontrarsi
[Musica]
rossi
sì
guarda ai santi e lo curò il telefono
dei monitori partire con le aspettative
sivori dentoni per tener carlo lucarelli
cult il novecento biondo tengono
superiore telecomunicazioni informatica
non si acquista da un po possibile la
persona moglie attiva
busca vicissimo la cuventu voi festival
e si elettronico il nome brusca crociere
ossea e voluti donando così come una
fune
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco allora questo vuol dire sicuramente
essere aperti agli altri ma esserlo non
nel classico modo ideologico teorico che
poi alla fine non funziona vuol dire
creare le occasioni per gli incontri e
capire che la diversità davvero ci
arricchisce e tutti abbiamo visto il
viso del ragazzo quando scopre che il
balla bambina nel primo nel primo film
ha davvero usato il suo denaro per
andare a scuola e abbiamo visto il viso
di queste persone che avevano pochi
secondi prima giudicato qualcuno aprirsi
al sorriso e aprirsi a quella che è la
vera empatia e la dimensione umana
tutto questo può avvenire anche in modo
veloce ecco il terzo paradigma e
qualcosa anche qui secondo me dobbiamo
accettare l'idea che la nostra sarà
sempre più una società di click sarà una
società veloce sarà una società in cui i
ragazzi useranno lo smartphone in un
certo modo google sarà la farà
sicuramente da padrone ma questo non
vuol dire che non si possa esprimere la
propria dimensione umana allora da
questo punto di vista ci possono essere
progetti veloci ma deep profondi con una
loro capacità di lettura e con la loro
capacità diciamo anche di coinvolgere
dal punto di vista emozionale ciascuno
di noi
e allora ecco l'ultima dimensione vado
veloce per rispettare il tempo perché è
importante che se c'è un tempo venga
rispettato ed è l'ultima dimensione che
è quella della dimensione naturale anche
qui siamo usciti dalla dimensione
dell'ecologia smo militante classico ma
molto spesso dobbiamo capire che
osservare gli animali che osservare la
natura le piante come vivono quali sono
le logiche profonde della loro vita
ancora oggi possa veramente essere per
né un'indicazione decisiva in questo
meraviglioso film che vi faccio vedere
addirittura le persone decidono è un
film non a caso giapponese
i giapponesi hanno questa straordinaria
capacità di imitare in modo profondo ed
è un film in cui alcune persone alcuni
attori imitano il corteggiamento degli
animali tra di loro come i de force e
quando si è innamorati si ha una
capacità di lettura dell'altro
dell'altro di cui si è innamorato che
diversa da quella che normalmente
abbiamo per le persone perché ci piace
tutto ci piace la città
ci piace il gesto ci piace quello che
normalmente consideriamo brutto solo
perché siamo in qualche modo innamorati
allora forza dobbiamo innamorarci un po
del nostro mondo e vediamo insieme
questa straordinaria capacità di lettura
del corteggiamento degli animali
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e poi bisogna essere anche precisi
spiegare quali sono le fonti e capire
quali sono le coppie che abbiamo
osservato e naturalmente i giapponesi lo
fanno e quindi qui troverete gli animali
che fanno quelle cose
g
[Musica]
ecco allora in chiusura quale può essere
il messaggio in chiusura il messaggio
può essere abbiamo il paese più bello
del mondo a disposizione la bellezza ce
l'abbiamo e la respiriamo tutti i giorni
molto spesso non ne siamo consapevoli
non lo capiamo
non abbiamo i linguaggi e i ritmi
necessari per poterla rilanciare quindi
invece di lamentarci di qualcuno che non
ci permette magari di fare quello che
desideriamo proviamo tutti noi a
rinnamorarsi di quello che è il nostro
mondo il nostro territorio il nostro
paese le persone che ci circondano credo
che se facciamo questo riusciremo
sicuramente a raggiungere il nostro
obiettivo per chi è interessato a questi
percorsi vi dico solo che in questo
stesso luogo il 17 giugno saremo come
festival della crescita quindi spero di
vedervi ancora tutti grazie
[Musica]